une dizaine d'appartements endommagés un
nouveau cadeau des Russes comme nous
l'explique Marina les dents serrées le
premier décembre un obus s'est abattu
sur cet immeuble par chance personne n'a
été blessé
on ne peut plus prévoir quand le
prochain bombardement va avoir lieu ça
arrive pendant la nuit mais aussi
pendant la journée il n'y a pas
d'installation militaire ou stratégique
à nicopole il y a des immeubles
résidentiels des jardins d'enfants et
voilà je comprends pas pourquoi elle
nous ciblesse je ne comprends pas ce
qu'ils ont dans leur tête
Marina nous emmène voir un habitant de
l'immeuble volody mire dont
l'appartement a subi des dommages
lui est encore sous le choc l'explosion
a été impressionnante
nous étions à la maison mais grâce à
Dieu nous étions dans la cuisine quand
l’obus nous a frappé il y a eu une
énorme explosion toutes les fenêtres ont
volées en éclat où ont été soufflés
l'appartement de sa voisine Tamara n'a
pas été touché la vieille dame est
résignée à 83 ans impossible pour elle
de partir elle vit seule elle a la
maladie de Parkinson depuis plus de 20
ans alors à quoi bon mais sa colère
contre les Russes reste intacte
je pensais que nous étions frères et
soeurs avec les Russes jamais je
n'aurais pensé qu'une telle chose puisse
arriver que la Russie pourrait commettre
de telles abominations venir ici et nous
détruire je ne les comprends pas et je
ne leur pardonnerai jamais toutes les
choses horribles qu'ils ont faites
rares sont les habitants croisés dans
les ruches sur 120 000 avant la guerre
plus de 60 000 sont partis ceux qui sont
restés se taire chez eux ou dans leur
cave d'autres viennent la journée pour
travailler et repartent ensuite le soir
se mettre à l'abri nous sommes à 7 km à
vol d'oiseau de la centrale nucléaire de
zapporis Jack qui est actuellement
occupé par les Russes nico-paul se
trouve juste en face la ville est
bombardée nuit et jour par l'artillerie
russe une trentaine de personnes a été
tuée depuis le début des bombardements
fin juillet
impossible pour les soldats Ukrainiens
de riposter distillent trop dangereux en
raison de la centrale nucléaire tant que
la guerre sévira nicopole restera une
ville vulnérable dans la ligne de mire
des Russes